so the first thing is to recognize the
notation so f of X equals okay this
right here okay it looks kind of a
strange symbol or sometimes what they do
is they put these little bars on the
bottom okay these little these little
bars right here and what that indicates
is that we're rounding down so you round
down okay to the to the low to the next
integer so I'll show you an example so
see if you have negative one point nine
nine so what you do is you look go to
your number line negative one point nine
nine is right here you round down which
is on the number line you round to the
left so this would put us here at
negative two now if we're at negative
one point one that's right here see it's
almost negative one but you're not quite
to negative one yet so you round down to
negative two again negative one we're
right on the integer value so that's
still gonna stay at negative one
negative point nine is right here your
round again to the left you always want
remember your round to the left when
you're doing this greatest integer
function negative point five you're here
again you're rounding down to negative
one zero
so you're on that integer value so that
stays at zero point five you're right
here you round again down to zero to the
left one
okay we're right on the integer value so
to stay at 11.1 you round again down to
one one point nine nine almost to two
but you have to round down to that next
you know integer there so that's one and
then two we're at two now the reason I
did this and you might want to do this
for yourself too as you're graphing this
is it pick some values that are on the
integer values and also in between
integer values think of the number line
and always around to the left round down
so what we're gonna do now is we're
gonna plot these over here on the graph
so at negative one point nine nine which
is right here we said that we're at
negative two so we're basically I'm
gonna put a point right there negative
one point one we're over here at
negative two
okay as soon as we get to negative one
it jumps up now you're at negative one
so what I'm going to do is want to put a
closed point right there over here I'm
going to write an open point so what
happened is we're approaching negative
one as soon as we got to negative one it
jumped up to negative one see at
negative point five you're at negative
one at negative point one you're still
at negative one but as soon as you get
to x equals zero we're open here we jump
up to zero here so what you can see is
after you plot a few of these you're
going to get the pattern and then you
can just go ahead and draw those stairs
or steps from there and you'll notice
that when you're doing this see how the
closed portion of the graph is on the
left and the open is on the right so
this is your basic graph and it
continues up to the right and down to
the left like that but let's look at
some other variations so somebody was
asking me on another video that I did
you know what happens if you have like y
equals negative greatest integer of X
well you see this negative what do you
think that does to the graph so these
are called you know transformations what
do you think that negative does well
what it does is it makes all these
values the opposite sign so if it's
positive now it's going to be negative
if it's negative it's going to be
positive so it reflects it over the x
axis so if we were graphing this just to
draw a little sketch here normally it
looks like this right and it would go up
to this next stare that's going to
reflect there gonna be going down now
like this right and so on okay now what
do you think for this next one y equals
two times the greatest integer of X what
do you think this two does to the graph
okay well what's interesting see if
you're comparing this one and this one
see this 2 is outside okay it's in front
of what this is going to do is going to
multiply all these values over here
times 2 so it's going to be a vertical
stretch so what's going to happen if we
graph this one let's just see if I can
plot this here for us is it's gonna be a
vertical stretch so normally you're
gonna be right here ok 0 times 2 is
still 0 but as soon as you get to 1
instead of being at 1 it's gonna be a 2
now so you're stretching it right
instead of being at over here at to now
you're gonna be at 4 ok so this is gonna
jump up like this and same thing when
you're over here at negative 1 now
you're gonna be down here at negative 2
ok so you're with me on that so the one
in front that's gonna be a vertical
stretch or if it's like a half of be a
vertical shrink or compressed now what
do you think this 3 does to the graph
right here notice is grouped with the
axis inside of those brackets okay those
greatest integer brackets what do you
think that 3 does to the graph now if
you if you said that it's going to
compress it
okay horizontally you're absolutely
right the one that's group with the axe
actually has the opposite effect so what
this is actually gonna do is actually
going to make these stairs over here one
third is long so if I can sketch that
here for us what this would look like
okay if I can just draw a few these here
for us is you would go like this you
would say I'm going up to one third then
I'm jumping up to one then I'm going to
two thirds then I'm jumping up to two
then I'm going over here to one then I'm
jumping up so what's happening is it's
actually compressing it horizontally now
if this was y equals ax divided by three
then it would have the opposite effect
it would actually stretch these okay
these stairs through these steps they
would actually be three units long
before it jumps up to the next stair so
this has been a little bit how to work
with greatest integer functions and
graphing them I hope this helped you
understand a lot better subscribe to the
channel check out more math tutoring
videos on my youtube channel Mario's
math tutoring and I look forward to
helping you in the future videos I'll
talk to you soon